former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie former Trump endorser Chris
Christie is going to be running against
Donald Trump and the other Republicans
in the primary field for the Republican
Presidential nomination NBC News is now
reporting former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie to announce his 2024
presidential bid on Tuesday it is
Christie's second run for the nomination
he will announce at a town hall in
Manchester New Hampshire two sources
were confirmed the article reminds us
that Chris Christie stumbled is the word
they used to a sixth place finish in
2016's New Hampshire primary axios was
the first to report the timing of
Christie's announcement after he dropped
out of the race eight years ago Christie
endorsed Trump days before super Tuesday
lending a credible name to Trump's
momentum uh another interesting aspect
to this is that ABC News is immediately
suspending its relationship with Chris
Christie Chris Christie has been a
analyst contributor sort of person on
ABC
ABC has announced that at least for now
they are suspending their relationship
with Chris Christie because he is indeed
becoming an official candidate so I'm
going to be very transparent with
everybody here if you came to Me Maybe
with tears in your eyes and said David
if you knew that one of the Republicans
currently running would be the next
president of the United States who would
you pick I pick Chris Christie and when
you say to me okay well there's Trump
there's DeSantis Nikki Haley Tim Scott
Mike Pence Vivek ramaswamy at this point
I don't even remember who else is
running you've got
um I guess ASA Hutchinson God forbid uh
no listen I mean from this group I go
with Chris Christie Chris Christie as a
New Jersey governor a blue state that
sometimes elects Republican governors in
the mode of what we've seen happen in
Massachusetts as well over the years
William weld Mitt Romney
um I I can't believe I'm blanking a
Charlie Baker more recently uh
I would I would be if you said forget
about Democrats it's just it's going to
be one of these Republicans I think I go
with Christy I actually think Christy is
more intelligent than a lot of the other
people he's running against I will
remind folks that this could be a factor
if Christy gets on the debate stage with
Trump
um Christy is actually pretty good in
debates and remember these moments back
from 2016 when Christy really made Marco
Rubio look stupid by pointing out that
Rubio is in a sort of talking point coma
repeating the same thing over and over
and over again remember this classic
moment you have not been involved in a
consequential decision where you had to
be held accountable you just simply
haven't say I want the people at home to
think about this that's what Washington
DC does the drive-by shot at the
beginning with Incorrect and incomplete
information and then the memorized 25
second speech that is exactly what
[Applause]
see see Marco
is this
when you're president United States when
you're a governor of a state the
memorized 30-second speech where you
talk about how great America is at the
end of it doesn't solve one problem for
one person this notion that Barack Obama
doesn't know what he's doing is just not
there it is he knows there it is to
memorize 25 seconds
you know what the shame is Marco the
shame is that you would actually
criticize somebody for showing up to
work plowing the streets getting the
trains run back on time when you've
never been responsible for that in your
entire life all right so listen Chris
Christie can debate I would be from an
entertainment standpoint I would be very
interested in seeing the approach that
Christy would take to Trump from a
pragmatic standpoint if I had to pick
from this group of Republicans who is
the next president
it would be Chris Christie and I think
probably by a long shot uh it is I think
maybe interesting or important to note
there are Maga people already making fun
of Chris Christie for being obese
Trump's obese it's stunning to me that
the supporters of one obese candidate
are making fun of another candidate for
also being obese I mean yes Christy
seems more obese than Trump I I saw some
tweets going around about uh uh Chris
Christie doesn't need to run for
president he just needs to run like go
out and jog in order to lose weight
if that's the best that the Maga people
can come up with against Christy I
actually am very interested to see
whether Chris Christie can get some
traction because he is quick he's got a
quicker wit he's smarter he has
experience as a prosecutor a sort of
experience that is uh lacking and in the
Republican primary and might actually be
interesting if confronted with Trump on
a debate stage so I'm going to be
following the Chris Christie candidacy
interesting uh closely and from an
interested perspective if it's Christy
versus Biden I'm voting for Biden
certainly I agree with Biden much more
on policy but I think that that's the
most interesting you know Vivek
ramaswamy so boring Tim Scott Dead on
Arrival who cares Pence oh my goodness
Pence might try to bore the audience
into submission uh but Chris Christie I
find a little bit interesting let me
know your thoughts make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube at youtube.com the
davidpackman show we'll take a quick
break and be right back if you've been
thinking about getting a new mattress
helix sleep is where I would start I've
been sleeping on Helix mattresses for
years now I recommend Helix to everyone
which is why I wanted them as a sponsor
if you don't want to take my word for it
Helix has been awarded number one
mattress by both GQ and Wired Magazine
and one of the things that makes Helix
unique is their sleep quiz I didn't
really know what kind of mattress would
be best for me but you do this short
sleep quiz you answer questions about
your body type and your preferences what
position you like to sleep in and Helix
will match you with the perfect mattress
for you so you know you're actually
getting something tailored to your needs
instead of going in blind like most
people do I got my Helix mattress
designed to stay cool at night since I
hate getting hot while I sleep shipping
is always free you get a hundred nights
to decide whether you like it my
audience gets a huge 20 discount off of
all orders plus two free pillows go to
Helix sleep.com slash Pacman the link is
in the description